there were long delays at some land
border crossings into canada as fully
vaccinated u.s citizens were finally
allowed across for the first time since
march of last year
but given the spread of the delta
variant and parts of the u.s
some are raising questions about the
relaxation of the rules
i'm a little nervous about it because
the numbers are going up there so much
that we've got one hundred thousand a
day so why
are we exposing ourselves
canada shut its borders to non-citizens
in march of 2020
for the deeply integrated communities
along the 8 500 kilometer frontier the
result was devastating
families have been separated fiances
husband wife
businesses it's taken a huge emotional
toll so i'm very excited that the border
is opening and
we're going to have some relief not only
must u.s citizens be fully vaccinated
but they also need proof of a negative
covert test taken within
72 hours of crossing the border but
although coveted free canadians have
been allowed to fly to
the u.s since the pandemic began the u.s
is keeping its land border with canada
closed to non-essential travel until at
least the 21st of august
citing the risk of covet clearly there's
a contradiction here because fully
vaccinated canadians can
fly into the us they just can't use the
land border so for example
that's windsor ontario that's detroit
michigan instead of using the one and a
half kilometer tunnel
between the two cities canadians are
having to drive four hours to toronto
and then fly to detroit
business leaders say the reason for the
discrepancy is what's happening on the
southern border
the bide administration fears that
opening the northern land border
will increase pressure to open its
border with mexico
and that's something it does not want to
do i think there's a lot of pressure
uh to treat border the borders the same
i don't know that that's 100 percent of
the reason but that certainly
plays into it in the meantime u.s
citizens at least can finally enter
canada from air
land and sea canada is expected to
loosen its entry restrictions for other
countries
on september the 7th shia britancy al
jazeera detroit michigan